Mariah Carey and her billionaire fiance
why is their wedding now in jeopardy no
one spent more time with Mimi this
summer than et so you know we have the
detail traditionals my third wedding
whatever it's not like I don't be
whatever I just mean like obviously
every married so is he he's not really
that type of like let me be the star
type person
her eyes excessive spending that's one
alleged reason the I Do's are on hold
but come on James Packer the so-called
4.5 billion dollar man knew exactly what
he was getting into back in January when
he proposed of course I'm not performing
at my wedding
it's over-the-top already to the top
enough I pride my dress last night if
you must know and it looks good power is
located French yes gorgeous you and
James have his and hers y'all here we
are how important is it to have his or
her yachts I think it's important enough
his in her and everything
another rumors that Mariah got a little
too close with one of her backup dancers
and her docu-series cameras caught it
Mimi's talked with us all about her male
crew that hot guys on the stage with me
did you see when he picked me up and
swirled me around any I know all about
very jealous loved all of that it was a
moment it's interesting one of her
dancers was there for Mariah's Halloween
party last weekend while James was
suspiciously absent but we did notice
Mariah still had on her estimated 7
million dollar engagement ring
but we've learned a relationship has
been on the rocks since last month
before the bash mariah's rep gave us
these details exclusively today mariah
james had a fight in greece and have not
seen each other since the fight was not
because of any cheating allegations or
excessive spending by mariah they are
trying to work it out right now they're
not sure they will stay together they
are discussing it and plan to release an
official statement together about their
future another thing adding pressure we
hear last week James lost around six
hundred million dollars on a failed
business deal in China on top of that 18
of his employees have been detained for
alleged gambling crimes I'm so exhausted